[Music]
sarah's in albuquerque new mexico hey
sarah welcome to the dave ramsey show
hi dave and christy thanks so much for
taking my call sir how can we help him
um well i just want to start off with
i'm 23 years
old um i just graduated with a master's
this year
and i got my first uh yeah full-time
job this may wow and um yeah and i've
been
living with my parents and i've been
having a pressure of like needing to
move out um
although i don't i feel like it's a
little too soon for that and
um oh mainly because i feel like i want
to
save up a little bit more to pay for
maybe a mortgage
a down payment and um yeah you need to
move
yeah okay yeah so you got a master's
degree in what
uh computer engineering good for you and
you got and you're employed in that
field
yes and you have an income of what uh a
hundred thousand
oh sarah get out of the house sarah
sarah sarah
i mean i feel like i should save you
from his answer right now
listen sarah you shouldn't have told him
that you shouldn't have told him
you should have just sugarcoated that
part listen there is a dignity that is
going to come with you moving out of
your house the joy that you're going to
experience to have your own place and
you absolutely
have the income you have to plenty of
time you have plenty of time to buy a
house later
get your name yeah i guess get your
apartment and get you a life
okay yeah it's okay obviously you have a
great relationship with your parents
which is
wonderful yes and um
one of uh my oldest daughter denise
lived with us for about three months
uh you're past that mark when she first
got out of school
just to get settled into the new job and
find the new apartment and actually
arrange some roommates and that kind of
thing and so forth and we loved having
her there and she loves us and we didn't
have any boundary issues or any
weirdness or anything like that
but it it all of um my grown kids are
older than you
i i have witnessed their um
[Music]
just the advancement of their uh
adulthood when they
uh had to buy their own groceries and
pay their own light bill and um and it
just it's just really good for you
and you got the money you're you're in
good shape and if something really
really bad happens and you need to
return home for
a safety net uh for a little while
you've always got that option given that
you've got a wonderful relationship with
him we can tell that because you're
under more
in no hurry to get out but my coaching
is just the old man on the show would be
get out
and i think you'll be glad you did in a
few years
uh or in a few months or maybe even a
few minutes
uh because it's your place there's a
there's a
christie used the word dignity and
that's a good word christy yeah it's
it's a pride and also just
it's this feeling of i am now officially
an independent adult when you're living
at home with mom and dad it's very hard
to feel that um because you're not
because you're still
a kid in their house and you can afford
it and so i think you're gonna actually
be so glad you did
and have that same thought like we were
just saying like man why didn't i do
that sooner and you know as denise met
bill and um that led
obviously that dating relationship led
to them getting married many years ago
she was in a different place because she
was a stand-alone
confident young woman she wasn't under
her daddy's
roof anymore right you know and she was
about that age actually right
um and so uh 23 24 years old probably
when she met bill something like that
and so um she would tell you that put
her in a different place to enter that
relationship
that's a good thing she had been still
at home with mommy and daddy yeah
you know and um it wasn't that she was
immature
it wasn't that she wasn't any of those
things but it just the confidence and
the sense of power
as a young woman that's independent and
i make my own decisions
you don't feel as vulnerable just you
know you don't need some guy to come in
right to save the day right and it
causes you to pick better
when you're looking at guys well that's
a great that's a great point it's
interesting too because matt you know my
husband matt he travels with his work
and when he's out of town i mean i think
this is gonna come
as no shock to anyone that knows me but
i don't freak out because i lived on my
own for
eight years nine years before we got
married so i know how to mow the lawn i
know how to fix something that goes
wrong when the pilot light goes out on
the water heater i know how to do stuff
because i did it and so it's not this
fear of like
i have to have him there in a panic when
he's out of town so there is a sense of
independence and also just
self-sufficiency confidence that occurs
yeah confidence and power
yeah those kinds of things and um that
affected your
you you when you met matt yeah i mean
you didn't you weren't
needy right in that sense and i'm not
saying that sarah's needy right no
no i didn't sense that i mean she's
making a hundred thousand dollars a year
she's a computer expert she's not saying
she's good
it's just it's a byproduct of moving out
on your own that you probably aren't
expecting that's what we're saying
you probably aren't even thinking of
that but those are other benefits you'll
experience for you moms and dads
listening that's why you kick them out
yeah they need that even if they don't
know they need